the AP
might disagree with Joe Biden on the
greatest threat in America
because according to the libs
one of the tippy-top threats is not just
white people but parents
according to the Associated Press this
might be my favorite headline I've ever
seen
trans miners protected from parents
under Washington law
the AP especially in recent years has
become a far left wing news Outlet
much worse than Reuters the AP is
supposed to cut it right down the middle
and then the newspapers can add their
own spin to it but the AP in recent
years has become so radically left-wing
the AP has its own style book which is
supposed to set the the norms for
journalism for all sorts of other papers
they have become radically pro-left Wing
radically pro-trans in recent years and
you see this headline trans miners
protected from parents under Washington
law
now this raises two questions
protected
from what
by whom
if the AP if they were good journalists
they would tell you but they don't
protected from what by whom well they're
being protected from
their biological reality they're being
protected from the traditional
understanding of what a man is and what
a woman is they're being protected from
the truth they're being protected from
behaviors that will allow them to
flourish they're being protected from
normative behaviors that will very
likely allay the mental and spiritual
problems they're suffering from
and who are they being protected by
they're being protected by people who
I'll put it as gently as I can
don't have all their marbles okay
they're being protected
from those evil awful parents by people
who are seriously messed up they're
being protected by people like this
uh putative young woman looks a little
masculine to me who just appeared at a
Board of Supervisors meeting in San
Francisco and was frankly one of the
most articulate Defenders of
transgenderism I've ever heard
Walgreens Garden security and to guard
that Lynch the crook jet the a
Jenkins London breed Stephanie
cop again in stores he mandelman
off I.E muslin guardio
Petey Chief Scott epw homeless
sweeps
drama scoring
those who recall chase a padine school
board recallers that lie
shelter first Josephine child
understands Trump Republicans and Richie
Greenberg John Dennis out Stein
Twitter trolls and drug
Warriors and the lying press
suit Heather White Knight chill Tucker
Carlson Fox suits and crier Reynolds
wow yeah okay that really that's
something I'm just taking notes
so that I don't forget any of those
important arguments and by the way
that's as strong an argument for
transgenderism as I have ever heard
don't forget I was scheduled to debate
perhaps the most erudite trans
identifying defender of transgenderism
in the entire country a man with three
Harvard degrees a man with half a dozen
honorary doctorates a man with two dozen
academic Publications
he knew my views on transgenderism we
had spoken beforehand he knew exactly
what to expect from my side of the
debate the kind of arguments that I was
going to make and so at the last minute
he pulled out why because nobody can
defend this stuff
Washington law now will protect trans
miners you know that totally real
category of people trans miners
from their parents what is that they're
going to protect kids from their parents
they're going to say that guy who
appeared at the San Francisco Board of
Supervisors meaning he should have much
more influence over a confused child
than his awful evil parents are that's
that's the neutral middle ground in our
culture
that's it we're going to have to be
rather subversive and wise a serpent and
listen to his dubs
to overcome that right now text Knowles
to 98 98 98 president Trump recently
issued a warning from his Mar-A-Lago
home quote our currency is crashing and
will soon no longer be the world
standard which will be our greatest
defeat frankly in 200 years there are
three reasons the central banks are
dumping the U.S dollar inflation deficit
spending and our insurmountable national
debt the fact is there's one asset that
has withstood famine Wars and political
and economic upheaval dating back to
Biblical times gold you can own gold in
a tax sheltered retirement account with
the help of Birch gold that's right
Birch gold will help you convert an
existing Ira or 401K maybe from a
previous employer into an IRA in Gold
the best part is you don't pay a penny
out of pocket text Knowles kwels to 98
98 98 for your free info kit they will
hold your hand through the entire
process you think about this when
currencies fail gold is a safe haven how
much more time does the Dollar have
protect your savings with gold today
Birch gold has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers text Knowles Canada wlas
to 98 98 98 and get your free info kit
on gold that is Knolls to 98 98 98. feel
good story of the day if not the year
13 year old boy
saved his sister from being kidnapped
with a slingshot
so there's an eight-year-old girl she
was playing out around her backyard she
was hunting for mushrooms when an older
teenage male 17 year old guy comes out
of the woods and tries to kidnap her
he said when the guy was apprehended
later he said he wanted to beat the girl
he was open about what he was trying to
do
so this 13 year old boy sees this
happening pulls out his slingshot and
just dings this guy right in the head
and then at that moment the girl had the
opportunity to run away and then the 13
year old got him again and so the the 17
year old ran off but the fact that he
was pinged in the head with the rocks
made it easier to apprehend him
and so he's now been arrested
really really great news
he's now been charged with kidnapping
child enticement One account one count
of attempted assault to do great bodily
harm less than murder one can of assault
and battery okay happy ending to the
story I bet everybody who hears that
story is going to say this is a really
great happy story
thank goodness that little boy had a
slingshot he's like a regular old Bart
Simpson boy could you imagine it if he
hadn't had a slingshot what would have
happened to that girl
that we need to give all these young
boys slingshots
I bet you 95 of people at least 99 of
people hear that story would come to
that conclusion
then some people would fail to follow
the logic of that story
to our second amendment rights
they would say well no that's totally
different it's good to give young
teenage boys slingshots but it's bad for
adults to be able to protect themselves
from bad guys
but seventeen-year-old Mohawk kids
coming out of the woods those aren't the
only bad guys they're bad guys at every
single age
and you're going to face more bad guys
later on in your life for the bulk of
your life when you're an adult than you
will for the few years that you're a
teenager
so how do you how do you bring that home
it's a point on political rhetoric the
way that politicians succeed is when
they make things really simple
if you want to defend the Second
Amendment get bring this story in your
back pocket this is it this is how Trump
has been very successful this is how
Ronald Reagan was very successful we
don't need to give long discourses on
natural rights and natural law and
self-protection and the technical
details of how guns work I'm all for
that stuff I find that terribly
interesting but when you're talking to
the libs
this is what's going to do it you say
goodness gracious could you imagine what
happened what would happen to that
eight-year-old girl had that boy not had
a slingshot
yeah that's the same thing's true for 25
year olds though and when you're 25 the
bad guys they're not just carrying rocks
and sticks
they've got knives and guns too and so
the same principle is in effect there
wouldn't it be terrible if the bad guys
got to kidnap people beat people up do
even worse to people
that's it you keep it very you keep
things very very simple was that wasn't
that a line from James Carville keep it
simple stupid
how great a clip was that I know I'm
with you if you want more of it if you
want long-form interviews if you want
The Daily Show if you want the yes or no
game if you want it all you got to ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles show see you next time